bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce vlog 3 où je vais vous
accompagner en face caméra et en voix
off
tout au long des images que vous allez
voir parce que je vous emmène en
randonnée dans deux départements la
lozère puis le larzac où j'ai donc filmé
pendant les randonnées et comment vous
dire
les enregistrements sonores étaient
vraiment pas bons tout simplement parce
que je suis pas partie avec un micro
externe dans le sac à dos pour m'éviter
du poids supplémentaire et donc il y
avait énormément de vent parce qu'on
était sur des hauts plateaux et c'est
franchement pas folichon donc je préfère
commenter ici les images que vous allez
voir et puis à la fin du vlog là pour le
coup ce sera un format vlog classique où
c'était un autre jour il y avait
quasiment pas de vent et vous
m'entendrez très bien
la première chose qu'on est allé voir
c'est une enceinte protohistorique sur
le causse méjean
donc c'est en lozère, alors une enceinte
protohistorique qu'est ce que c'est ?
c'est une construction à but défensif
qui est une sorte d'enclos muré qui
date donc de la protohistoire.
La protohistoire c'est, alors là en
particulier cette enceinte
protohistorique elle date de la tène
donc c'est à peu près le ivème siècle
avant jésus-christ, une enceinte
protohistorique elle a deux fonctions
principales
la première elle est défensive c'est à
dire que au centre de cette enceinte est
bien il ya des îlots d'habitation que
qu'on ne voit plus aujourd'hui je
pourrai pas vous les montrer et à
l'extérieur on mettait les espaces
funéraires donc les endroits où on
inhume les morts.
Cette fonction défensive eh ben elle est
renforcée par l'endroit où se situe
l'enceinte c'est à dire sur un point
culminant. On a donc une vue globale du
causse méjean et on peut se protéger des
envahisseurs. Et enfin la dernière
fonction de ces enceintes
elle peut être aussi esthétique c'est à
dire que ça peut être agréable pour les
habitants d'habiter sur un point
dominant qui vous offre une vue
spectaculaire.
Pour vous donner une idée de la taille
de cette de cette enceinte je crois
qu'elle fait 150 mètres de diamètre ce
qui est assez vaste et d'ailleurs vous
pouvez la voir sur google earth je vous
mettrai les coordonnées en barre d'infos
ou je vous ferai une capture écran de
l'affichage vous pouvez donc voir
l'enceinte, cette forme circulaire qui se
dessine dans le paysage. Et alors
l'enceinte, ce mur au départ est estimé à
4 mètres de hauteur et nous ce qu'on a
vu on voyait au maximum 2 mètres de
hauteur donc les pierres qui manquent
elles ont été tout simplement récupérées
par les habitants, les bergers depuis bas
depuis des siècles et des siècles pour
d'autres constructions. Cette enceinte
elle s'appelle l'enceinte
protohistorique de la rode et l'accès
est assez facile en fait il faut prendre
un gr qui part du village qui s'appelle
Drigas je sais pas vraiment
comment on prononce ce village et vous
avez quelques kilomètres et même vous
pouvez faire une grande balade une sorte
de boucle qui fait une dizaine de
kilomètres et qui vous fait passer par
cette enceinte
ensuite on a quitté la lozère et on est
parti dans le larzac
toujours pour faire des randonnées c'est
quelque chose qu'on aime beaucoup faire
moi et mon compagnon et ça nous a permis
de découvrir d'autres sites
archéologiques notamment des dolmens et
un site de l'antiquité donc bien plus
récent
alors avant de vous parler un peu plus
de ces découvertes de vous les montrer,
Ces vlogs là ça me permet de rappeler
quelque chose qui est très important en
archéologie et qu'on a tendance à
oublier ou tout simplement à ne pas le
prendre en compte
c'est tout ce qui touche à la
prospection. La prospection c'est une
grosse partie du boulot des archéologues
c'est à dire que entre les fouilles de
terrain qui se passe souvent l'été et
les rédactions de rapports de fouilles
qui se déroulent le plus souvent l'hiver
est bien les archéologues prospectent.
prospecter ça veut dire marcher, aller sur
le terrain essayer de découvrir des
futurs lieux de fouilles et donc moi bah
c'est vlogs sauvages j'ai envie de plus en
plus de les orienter vers des vlogs
découvertes archéologiques parce que ça
fait partie de ma formation
ça fait partie de ce que j'aime faire
c'est-à-dire randonner et avec des
outils google earth des gps et des
cartes ign trouver des sites
archéologiques puis j'espère qu'ainsi
vous pouvez comprendre que l'archéologie
c'est pas forcément des sites
touristiques ou l'entrée est payante
avec un fascicule qu'on vous donne à l'entrée
mais que vous pouvez tout simplement
découvrir des sites en marchant parce
que des sites archéologiques y en a
partout partout sous vos pieds dans les
montagnes.
il suffit juste de chercher !
Donc ensuite au larzac on est allé voir des dolmens et un oppidum.
Donc les dolmens ils étaient très intéressant pour
différentes raisons
le premier c'était intéressant parce que
on pouvait voir encore l'emprise du cairn
le cairn c'est le tas de pierres qui
recouvre la chambre et bien souvent on a
en mémoire seulement les grandes dalles
mégalithiques qui font la chambre
funéraire est bien celui ci on pouvait
voir au sol vous voyez il ya des pierres
et puis à un endroit elles s'arrêtent et on
retrouve l'herbe et bien ça ça nous
donne une idée de l'emprise de la taille
originelle de ce monument.
après un peu plus loin on est allé voir un autre dolmen qui doit dater à peu près de la
même époque je sais pas précisément mais
je dirais 3000 avant jésus-christ qui
lui à l'inverse n'avait plus du tout les
pierres du cairn c'est à dire que toutes
les pierres ont été pillées récupérées par
les bergers par les habitants pour les
enclos des brebis ou pour des
constructions des maisons dans les villages
alors ces deux dolmens si ça vous
intéresse, si vous voulez allez voir, ils
sont du côté de la cavalerie c'est le
nom du village qui est le long de la grande
deux fois deux voies qui part de Millau
ensuite on est donc allé voir un oppidum
est donc là je vous laisse avec les
images qui suivent parce que les
conditions météorologiques étaient
meilleures que les autres jours et on
entend très bien et au moins on retrouve
un format vlog classique
donc là on vient d'arriver sur le site
de l'oppidum
je vais me mettre à l'abri du vent pour
pouvoir vous expliquer un petit peu ce
que c'est déjà un oppidum n'y a pas de
vent alors un oppidum c'est le nom que
donnaient les romains aux villes gauloises
et donc oppidum c'est un oppidum des
oppida
ça veut dire ville fortifiée et donc ça
peut comprendre des sites immenses
comme on en a en Auvergne à Bibracte
qui est donc un oppidum qui est situé
sur le mont beuvray
là c'est vraiment immense et d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il ya toujours des fouilles
en cours depuis depuis des années et ça
peut être aussi des structures
beaucoup plus réduites comme ça à l'air
d'être le cas ici.
mais y'a des choses assez intéressantes alors y avait un
petit panneau explicatif qui nous dit
donc que, l'oppidum de la
granède, il y a trois phases
occupation en mille avant jésus-christ
il ya un premier première en 1000 av. donc là c'est vraiment de la
protohistoire ensuite on a une
occupation au 2e et 1er siècle avant
jésus-christ donc là c'est vraiment la
conquête romaine et ça se voit très bien
sûr au niveau de l' architecture et
après on a une dernière occupation au
bas-empire donc c'est ivème siècle après
jésus-christ et ça par contre je
n'arrive pas on n'arrive pas à le voir
la sur sur les restes sur les vestiges
mais on va descendre là je suis vraiment
au dessus de la muraille et on va
descendre je vais vous montrer sur les
sur les murs comment on peut voir ça
ok donc là on voit c'est ça qui est
intéressant on voit bien les trois phases
au moins les deux phases de
construction on a une première
constructions en très gros appareil en
très gros blocs de pierre qui a pas du
tout la même inclinaison que ce qui a au
dessus et au dessus c'est la deuxième
phase donc là c'est vraiment époque
romaine on voit bien parce que c'est des
pierres plus petites et qui sont
construites en ligne c'est hyper
régulier ça c'est typique de la
construction romaine et la dernière
chose au dessus on a ce que moi
j'appelle de la caillasse, c'est du gravas et parce
qu'en fait la construction romaine c'est
du parement c'est des belles pierres en
apparence et c'est un caisson et à
l'intérieur vous venez mettre des
pierres de mauvaise qualité pour remplir
votre mur et c'est vraiment c'est un
super bel exemple d'architecture on voit
bien les différentes phases le dernier
stade moi je n'arrive pas à le lire là
je ne sais pas vraiment où
est ce qu'on peut bien le voir et le
dernier truc que je voulais vous montrer
ce sont deux gouttières qui sont ici là
on est donc à l'angle de là je vous ai
parlé j'étais par ici ce sont les deux
gouttières deux blocs ici qui sont
d'ailleurs au bout d'une espèce de
je sais pas si c'était une voie d'accès
ici donc ça ce sont des pierres qui sont
creusées par la main de l'homme
et puis c'est accentué par le passage de
l'eau et donc ça vient récupérer les
eaux de pluie donc on voit bien
les cupules ou est récupérée l'eau et
donc le site est bien là il continue en
fait on monte alors sur le panneau il
explique qu'il ya différentes voies
d'accès qu'ils ont retrouvées et qui
permettait d'avoir des échanges
commerciaux avec millau et à millau il
ya deux rues qui sont
sont en fait faites sur les anciennes
voies romaines et est donc c'est un site
qui est assez vaste qui était en hauteur
avec un superbe panorama au bout et
c'est hyper propre
je sais pas
du tout quand est-ce qu'ils ont fouillé
ça ça doit être assez ancien la fouille
mais ça vaut le coup. Faut marcher un
petit peu on a marché 2
kilomètres à peu près pour y accéder et
là je vous emmène au point culminant
avec un superbe panorama
un gros nuage de pluie arrive on va voir si
ça rend quelque chose. un peu de ces
Y'a un peu de céramique qui a été découverte apparemment
là c'est de la sigillée qui est donc
produite sur un atelier en bas à
millau qui s'appelle la Gaufresenque et qui produit ce type de céramiques
très fine avec un engobe rouge
avec un aspect vernissé c'est comme si on
avait passé un vernis
c'est des poteries qu'on reconnaît très
très facilement voilà parfois on peut
mettre un petit engobe blanc pour
décorer
là l'oppidum ce que je vous ai montré
les remparts c'est ici, millau et à
droite et donc on voit bien que la
falaise
ça crée un rempart naturel et ça permet
de se défendre
on va terminer ce vlog ici nous rentrons
à Lugdunum, la
capitale j'espère que ces vlogs archéo
vous plaise j'aimerais bien en faire un peu
plus donc c'est un petit peu un test
celui ci. n'hésitaez pas à me dire
dans les commentaires si ça vous a
plu et pour continuer à nous emmener
dans des endroits comme ça que je connais
pas moi même et que je découvre en même
temps que vous au final voilà
prenez soin de vous à la prochaine salut